I am about to cross a road,
and here is something you might not know:
In Britain, there are special crossings for horses.
Not kidding. Because what I'm on is technically known as a 'bridleway'.
It's a footpath that horses and riders can use as well.
So here we have a special button--
there's one up there as well
for if you're already mounted on your horse--
and a special staging area,
that I'm currently standing in,
in which horses can wait
before the lights change
and they are able to cross the road that way.
And here is the best part:
the best part is the name,
because in Britain we have Pelican crossings, ""Pedestrian Light Controlled"
they're the normal ones.
And then they came up with Toucan crossings,
because they were for pedestrians and bikes,
so "two-can" cross there.
Then they came up with Puffin crossings--
I can't remember why they're called that--
but they're the ones with the special cameras and lights,
like those up there--
that will track pedestrians as they cross
and not stop the traffic any more than they have to.
And then, because all those are named after flying things:
we have this,
which is a Pegasus crossing.
And that is something you might not know.
[Closed captions by MM. Translating these subtitles? Add your name here!]